- The slowdown in the Chinese economy
doesn't just hurt China.
Some US companies do a
lot of business there
and have counted on the emerging economy
to help drive their profits.
During the second quarter,
S&P 500 companies
mentioned China 182 times.
That was the fewest number
of times since the fourth quarter of 2021.
But as the third quarter
earning season starts to heat up
in the US,
there are three big reasons
you're likely to hear a lot more
about China from American companies.
First, companies that generate big chunks
of their revenue from
China are driving much
of the stock market's gains this year.
The S&P 500 index is weighted based
on how large each company in the index is.
And in recent years,
tech companies have come to dominate.
Companies like Tesla, Apple and NVIDIA
have been responsible for much
of the rise in the S&P this year
and they all do a lot
of business in China.
While only 7.5% of revenue for companies
in the SS&P 500 comes from China,
about 16% of revenue for companies
in the information technology
sector is China-based.
For semiconductor companies like NVIDIA,
27% of revenue originates there.
And when the Chinese economy slows down,
like it has this year, that
usually means Chinese businesses
and consumers buy less.
That includes US products.
Second, we've seen rising
tensions between the US and China
with both countries
recently unveiling new
restrictions on trade.
Sources told my colleague
Yoko Kubota in September
that officials at central
government agencies
in China have been told
not to bring Apple's iPhone
to the office.
And Beijing recently instituted a ban
on Chinese firms buying products
from Idaho-based chip maker Micron.
The company said earlier
this year that the ban
could have a quote, "Double
digit percentage impact
on its total sales."
China has also ramped up bans
on foreigners leaving the country,
targeting bankers and executives.
The US has also made things more difficult
for American companies
doing business in China,
banning the sale of chips
and other tech equipment
to Chinese companies.
NVIDIA's chief financial
officer recently said
that further restrictions on
sales to China would result
in a quote, "Permanent loss
for the US industry to compete
and lead in one of the
world's largest markets."
Third, the Chinese economy
slowdown is having a wide range
of negative effects.
China's unemployment rate is picking up,
especially for young people who are some
of the biggest consumers
of American-made products.
The unemployment rate for
people aged 16 to 24 has doubled
over the past four years
and rose to 21% in June,
the highest level ever.
China's government suspended the survey
after June's record reading
and has cut off data releases
for corporate registration
information, patents, and more.
The countries yuan currency
also fell to its lowest level
in 16 years against the dollar last month.
That means products sold in China
will be more expensive for local consumers
or they'll have to be
marked down in dollar terms,
which means less money
comes back to US companies.
Companies may still be
able to hit their targets
despite these headwinds from China
but get ready to hear a lot more
about them in the coming weeks.
(dramatic music)